For today's video,
we are going to do some mobile development and I don't mean developing for
mobile. I mean, using a mobile device to develop,
I am going to code and deploy a web app while using nothing more
than a single phone. And my weapon of choice,
the iPhone 11 pro max S plus limited
edition two 56 gigabytes.
There's an issue when I make videos. When I make a YouTube video,
I have no idea if the thumbnails are interesting or not,
I wish I can AB test them, but I can't. As you know,
thumbnails are extremely important because it can make or break your video
no matter how good your video is. If it doesn't get clicked,
it doesn't get watched.
So I wish I can test my thumbnails to a small audience before I
publish it.
So I had an idea why not create a web app where people can decide between two
thumbnails,
which would the read or click and use that information to build a ranking system
of your thumbnails and other people's thumbnails.
So you can know how well you rank against others probably wouldn't work
because people don't want to click dumb thumbnails for no reasons.
It doesn't matter if it's a pet project, whatever it's settled,
we are ranking thumbnails. And to do that,
I need a ranking algorithm. Yep.
I need an algorithm.
Can you just tell me that it was BS,
reading off a total of 400 at any given time from now he has reading our eight.
Some of the B has writing RB.
When any two thumbnails are matched up,
there's an expectation of who will win based on their current rate.
Right? Yep. And those expectations are expressed this way. All right,
let's call it.
Oregon. And he is stack. And I think I found the perfect candidate. No,
J S she is a wild card.
Sometimes she makes no sense, but God I'd be lying to you.
If I said she isn't high performance with that single threaded event driven
architecture,
you cannot deny her abilities to handle multiple simultaneous connections
alone. She's pretty impressive already,
but paired for web framework mindblowing,
and nobody else makes no Jess shine brighter than this one express a
lightweight, no J S wet application framework together.
They aren't the definition of synergy.
And then there's Mongo DB,
the supplier stores and distributes data like no one else,
highly available, highly scalable,
finally angular J S the face of the operation.
If you ever need a con man, he's your guy.
And together they form the beat stack.
So basically we want a web server,
no JS web server, you know,
when you use express also, and then for the front end,
we're going to want angular. So,
so I'm essentially creating a simple diagram of a typical mean stack as a
skeleton, and then filling in more things like my model is schema.
So for our thumbnail,
we're going to be needing the URL of the YouTube URL,
and then maybe like a rating so that we can actually rank them.
We did our title,
and then also the image URL so that we can actually access the thumbnail.
So that's going to be our model.
Now I continue to put details and start expanding by adding things like
the services that I will use and how these services will interact with each
other. For example,
we have Heroku a platform as a service to host our node JS
application. So we don't need to deal with servers M lab,
a database as a service.
So we don't need to maintain our own database and the AWS servers.
So I can actually use a normal operating system like coupon to,
since iOS isn't made to code on,
you're not going to be able to use your phone as a computer,
but you can SSH into that AWS server.
And you can do that with an app called Terminus.
I think it will be easier than I thought,
because once you SSH into your AWS server,
you're essentially controlling a computer and you can follow any tutorial as if
you were on a desktop and just code like you would and Villa
the diagram of our interests.
Right. So I've set all my cameras up finally. Okay.
That took a lot more effort than I thought. So let's start coding. Okay.
So the first thing we want to do, as you know,
I will be coding the whole app using only my phone.
So from searching on the internet to coding and deploying the app,
everything has to be done on the phone.
So my goal is to set up a workable development environment and be able to push
to some sort of production environment. So my plan is to do the following,
generate a key pair for my phone,
and then AWS server launched AWS.
[inaudible] using my web browser on my phone.
I says H into my ECE to using my phone,
push a no JS app onto Heroku for production set up node
Mon to develop faster locally and last but not least just coat the entire
app. Easy. All right, let's see how I'm doing.
Copy that. Copy.
All right. And then we can generate, wow. This is,
this is not very good on mobile, to be honest. Well, I mean,
it's not their fault. It's not meant to be on mobile, but okay.
So then now we're going to import keys.
So basically I import the key pair into AWS so that I can use it when I launch a
new [inaudible] instance, but launching it,
isn't quite as easy of the UI on the foal.
I can't see anything. I can't see. Okay. Well, um, I could see that kind of,
I could kind of see the symbols. I want Uber one too, so, Oh, that's one.
I think that's 18. Okay. I want the 16.04. This is, uh,
I think,
wait. All right, cool. I can't see. Okay.
These buttons don't work. So for, this is our first obstacle.
Um, Oh, let's try this.
Okay.
All right. There we go. Easy. Okay.
So we're just going to launch this after I configured all my ports to be open
to any IP address, because I'm promiscuous like that.
I launched my ECE two and took a little ASM Mar break while I wait for it to
boot up.
Oh my God.
I then configured a new host for termi.
So I can SSH into my AWS server on my AWS server.
I installed no JS installed Teamworks,
pushed a starter app to Heroku and got node Mon to work.
So I can quickly test my app indexes. Okay, cool.
Let's change. Let's change the word. Getting started. That's due, right.
Joma here. Okay.
And then what we do now is we save the file.
Okay. So now we saved the file. We refreshed us. Oh,
excellent. Joma started on Heroku. Excellent. All right. So now we have it.
So we can code here, could use VIM to code, and then we could like use node,
want to keep running it.
And we could look at this link to see if it works or not. Okay.
So now I'm going to take a break cause like that took way too long for,
what's supposed to take two minutes, but I, because I did on a phone,
it took super long. I mean, I haven't figured out all the tricks yet,
so maybe I'll figure that out while I code it. So, um, yeah.
Okay. I'll work on it.
[inaudible]
the code can be separated into three parts. First, the backend,
which I copy pasted from this tutorial,
I just replaced the bear by thumb and modified the API appropriately for my
needs. Then for the webpage, I just needed a simple bootstrap template,
a few modifications, and some bytes CSS was sufficient. Lastly,
our angular JS code,
I put my data binds in the right places and I was able to connect my application
data to the dome.
So, so basically my left thumb and my kind of my right thumb hurts,
but mostly my left. And, um, yeah,
I think it's because I've been coding a project on my fault,
right? Yeah. It's it's for a video. So,
so I had to like call the whole project, like according to project on my phone.
And then every time like I swipe to go to like Chrome and stuff like that.
That's where it hurts. Like when I do this. Right. Um, okay.
Um, when did it start? Uh, like maybe like two weeks ago.
Cause that's when I started doing the coding project. Oh, okay. Well,
have you considered that? Maybe it's related to how you're using your phone.
Yeah, but I mean like, is there like any way where we can like type,
felt pain because like I still have to do that project? No, I don't think so.
I think you just have to stop using your phone so much.
I don't think I can finish this app on my phone.
Unfortunately, my thumb hurts and it hurts a lot.
Every time I swipe or like I type, there's just this really sharp pain,
right. There's really, really sharp pain.
And I don't think I can continue doing this.
Like it's probably not possible,
but I mean, there is this one thing that I can do
by really, really didn't want to rely on this,
but I don't think I have any other choice.
This is great. I am loving it. Oh my God.
I am blazing fast.
This is so good. Oh wow.
This is probably the best thing that ever happened to me.
All right. I am done.
Let me show you a little demo now let's go here.
Yeah. It's pretty simple. As you can see,
I'm clicking these thumbnails and each time I click a thumbnail,
it means the match has been won by that thumbnail. And if you click at the top,
you get the result page and here you can see the results of your ranking.
You can see it ratings and it's ordered by ratings, you know. Cool, cool,
cool. You can add more thumbnails, actual,
I'm going to delete all these thumbnails first.
So here I pasted a YouTube URL and I get their thumbnail right here.
I could also add my own thumbnail that is not attached to a
YouTube video, you know, and give it a title tiger King.
And there you go. And if you look at the main page,
you'll see that these two thumbnails are going head to head. All right.
And then after given a pink, a win, you'll see that the score has increased.
So that's pretty much it very simple app with lots of potential to add more
features. But for now, I'll just keep it at that.
Keep it simple since it's supposed to be a toy project so I can show off my
phone dev skills and uh, yeah. That's, uh, that's pretty much it.
Yeah. All right. Well,
I'm glad it's over. Um, yeah, I'm so done with my phone.
Like my eyes hurt. My thumbs are, you know,
I think I needed a digital cleanse and um, I think that's why I'm going to do,
you know,
I think I'm starting to appreciate disconnecting myself from the digital world,
you know, not be so blinded by technology and the internet. I mean,
especially social media, right? So maybe this is a good thing.
Like maybe finally I could get some reading done.
So I think that's what I'm going to do.
[Inaudible] Hey guys, I hope you've enjoyed this video. I definitely.
Enjoyed making it. Uh,
I just want to say that if you're interested in getting into Fang companies,
definitely check out the tech interview pro.com.
It's an online training program and professional community created by technique.
And I, uh, we teach you how to pass the technical interview,
the behavioral interview,
and you also get access to our private business groups where we give each other
tips and review each other's resumes.
You also get access to our live Q and A's where we answer all your questions.
So I really hope to see you guys there. See ya.